Kobus asks what would be your top three
tips for switching on your brain oh this
is an interesting question to me like
that Co this is an interesting question
to me I don't really know how to answer
it first of all I don't do well with you
know top three questions so vaynernation
don't ask me top three questions because
I don't even know how to gather my
thoughts in that way I'm not an active
enough thinker to execute that you know
I don't know I you know weirdly the only
thing that comes to me on this answer
it's why I took this question because
it's an interesting question is passion
it's a very lightweight answer it's a
fluffy answer but I truly believe that
is the answer meaning if you actually
love what you're doing if you actually
love it there's no friction to turn on
your brain the only time I feel like I
have to turn on my brain was when I was
six to 22 years old when I was going
through the [ __ ] education system of
America right that's what I felt like I
had to turn it on you know to appease
horse crap that didn't match my reality
but ever since that day we're like yay
and I went into like you need to buy
this Pinot Grigio the second that
started in May of 1998 there's never
been a day that I've had to activate
it's always on and I don't mean always
on buzzword marketing it's that I love
what I do so much that there is no
friction to turn it on even when I am
landing at two o'clock in the morning
from a flight that's delayed like the
other night and then going directly into
it at 6:30 in the morning because the
fire is so deep inside you love it so
much you know you don't need that
jumpstart oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe